Thursday pick show week 15 I'm jumping
right in watch out Thursday Night
Football Hunter Henry vs. Derek John Wow
matchup who do you give the edge to I'll
tell you what with Spencer we're out
there
they gotta be worried about priest
Holmes coming around the edge because
the last thing you need is junior se out
and the way Alex Smith spend playing
Windjammer is willing to hit that that
and LaDainian has been on fire oh my
gosh look if Steve Bono make the throw
to the flat yeah and find a way to get
to mark Bowe Rick goal but it's been
Humphrey what Ron means business start
getting on you sometimes I wonder
sometimes I go maybe Drew Brees will get
hurt and Dan Fouts I'll come in maybe
that'll be better for the charge I'm
glad we started this way holy crap
listen we're not that great at picking
games but realize that people picking
games it's 50/50 all we try and do is
know what we're talking about and give
you guys some good information can I say
my token line oh boy I don't know you
have like 17 is it quantifiable no self
scary I don't like oh but I've heard
Bill Belichick pick two games in my life
and he was wrong above yeah just say no
to games was it they were both playoff
games one was a Ravens game one was a
Ravens and one was a bangles game I want
to say like one of them was like I want
to go like one of them one of the years
the bangles lost you know they're five
in a row playoff games right yeah I want
to give a special shout out to the
people that hit me up in the DMS and
said way to fight through and battle the
sickness one person said I would
recommend not having hot chocolate
because the dairy may cause mucus course
I switched to tea right and now we're
gonna do the ceremonial pouring of the
emergency I just can't believe to our
Simpson left go water just touching your
mouthpiece and then maybe touch Sims
upset that Josh didn't thoroughly clean
these yeah which I would say is very
unlike Josh and that's the reason it's
surprising little scare I don't think
that's unlike Josh I think josh is a
little scared to get his like hands
dirty that's not true at all I was gonna
say every night in my apartment get
dirty you don't have a dishwasher
no I don't have a dishwasher in New York
neither do I you guys don't have
dishwashers no iowa's I got two of them
you know what I'm doing this I'm gonna
bring my dishes over to your house and
do my dishes there I pay I pay like
seventy dollars to handy so once a month
someone comes and clean and my sink
right now is full yeah waiting for that
person yeah pour your vitamin C in there
I did
that's a waste you should just give it
to me why you're already sick [ __ ] urine
you know this is gonna help me battle
back speaking of battling back Josh how
much just Sims have to battle back home
because I know he's behind all right
guys so here's what's happening in in
the betting pool right now so week 14
Sims you went seven and nine against the
spread left go you went eight and eight
against the spread right down the middle
Sims you lost 660 bleacher bucks last
week bringing you to a total of negative
900 on the season left go you made $0 Oh
$0 Wow on the season you are at 260
bleacher bucks okay so that's where
we're at so how much does that mean on
the head eleven hundred $60 but as we've
seen that could flip immediately yeah
but I like a little cushion heading into
week 50 I've been in trouble lately
last week Sims you went two and three
and guaranteed to lose so your record on
the season is 51 and 19 2 & 3 2 & 3
bucks and bangles both lost jets
dolphins and Raiders all won okay and
then left go one three one and three in
the locks you are at 24 29 and two any
questions about where we're at Tom Brady
played awesome though well he was
amazing no I just I am actually like I
said I think I did better picking the
games of the spread than I did picking
them outright
I don't think my record was seven and I
and if I korres wild cuz really was well
your big thing was you lost New England
and you lost Pittsburgh and you have
seven hundred and twenty dollars right
there yes it was all right Josh this
tangerine emergency is great I can't win
a big one I don't feel like it's even
mixed right I gotta like mix it again
yeah do it up it's why you got your
spoon all right guys first game of the
week here Thursday Night Football we
talked about it with big Phil yesterday
spread in this game is Kansas City
-
three and a half whether in KC tonight
cloudy low of 32 Chris take it away Ken
Derrick Johnson cover hunter Henry I
don't think again he's a little old oh
wait he played for the Raiders this year
and he's on the NFL anymore okay do you
believe I can't think of a Chargers
offensive tackle you do I get a hold one
oh I can actually do you think Lorenzo
Neal is gonna be able to chip Derrick
Thomas enough to give enough time Yeah
right all right Chris break it down okay
okay okay all right um all right well
the Chiefs offense versus the Chargers
defense
the Chargers defense we've talked about
this a lot lately you know it concerns
me that they're very small it really
does it's a I mean when you look at the
interior part of their defense
linebackers you're Tavis Brown Damien's
square other D tackles they're just not
great size they're they can be
overpowered in the run game now the
Chiefs don't run the ball so I don't
know if they're going to take advantage
of that but they do have an advantage
there I mean if there's ever a night for
Andy Reed not to say just to run 30
times but if he just runs at more than
15 and you have faith in Damien Williams
I do
I like Damien Williams they always have
really yeah I really have every right
time in Miami you're right I have I I
think he has potential yes I think he
can make some hard yards and I think if
he has a seam he's that has the type of
speed where he can he can rip off some
chunk plays I think the end of the day
were just this matchup all together I
don't expect the Chiefs to be able to
slow down the Chargers a whole lot
either okay
but I will say that playing in in Kansas
City again an LA team going to the cold
it's just not as easy to be the
high-flying we're gonna throw for 400
yards type a team in those type of
elements on a grass field the fans are
really loud D Ford and Justin Houston
can get a jump on the count a little bit
they have the advantage there so I guess
what I'm saying is more or less the
simplicity of the Chargers defense their
lack of size I think it's gonna have a
hard time matching up with the Chiefs
I do think it'll take a Bosa or a Melvin
Ingram you know more than one incredible
play for them to have a chance to win
the football game
the Chiefs protect the power
sir pretty well though and the Chargers
don't do a lot on a defense you've heard
me say that and I just think it's too
much for their defense to overcome with
a guy like Patrick mahomes who makes you
defend more square inches of the field
than any other quarterback in the sport
right now with that offense and Tyree
kill and all of that and Tyree kill it
sounds like he's good to go I know he's
still in the questionable tag either way
um yeah I expect this to be a fun
scoring game but the Chiefs to pull away
at the end okay I am going $200 on the
Kansas City Chiefs and I'm picking them
to win die die mr. lightning bolt
I go 34 24 Chiefs turn it out so to add
on to that Chargers this morning we're
recording this Thursday afternoon
promoted a practice squad running back
to the main roster which makes me think
that Melvin Gordon really is in bad
shape the really incredible his
questionable sounds different than
Tyrese does yeah the Chiefs in their
past 20 games against the AFC West their
own division are 19 and 1 that's
unbelievable Andy Reid's dominance over
this division they've beaten the
Chargers nine in a row yeah that's
amazing
Andy Reed did this in the NFC East -
yeah he's incredible he is I'm going a
hundred dollars on the Chiefs - three
and a half I had it at 36 to 30 right I
just I I honestly think this is how I
imagined the game's gonna start yeah
Eric battery gets announced Arrowhead is
crab solutely bumping right bumping
right Chiefs get out to a lead Chargers
come back Chiefs Chargers Chiefs no
Chargers cheese no chargers and sheep
right that's kind of yeah I think I
think that's right I think the Chiefs
jump out to an early lead the Chargers
go uh-oh here they come right it's I
think we're gonna talk about these
offenses is the Chris Jones and the D
Ford's making the play right or is the
Derwin james's and the BOCES yeah all
right that's it's really I think where
it comes down to I'm with you
all right guys moving on for
Saturday football game of the year the
Texans visiting the New York Jets Chris
just you know high of 55 in the New York
area on Saturday perfect weather for
Christmas here in New York is Houston -
six
yeah Houston - six okay the first thing
I worry about I mean that I have a hard
time thinking that the Jets can do a
whole lot against this Texans offense I
mean the Jets Oh lines you know middle
of the road that's all it is they can
run the ball decent they're okay at past
protecting you know their offensive
scheme is not groundbreaking so I don't
think they can do enough to expose some
of the crazy coverages the Texans can at
certain that can run at certain times
yeah I think this is a tough matchup for
the Jets offense because I do think of
the Jets offense it's a hair predictable
way and we just cut the alert that
Isaiah Crowell and quits you are outside
so they're in deep crap and I should
have bet more money on this but either
way yeah I would have a hard time
thinking that the the Texans defense
doesn't have its way with the Jets also
though I'll throw this on the other side
I don't think the Texans are gonna have
their way with the Jets d either I don't
think so yeah I mean this again you've
heard me complain about this the Texans
offense when they can't run the ball
they lack a little creativity in the
pass game just there's no other way to
say it they kind of just rely on
Watson's talents we're gonna block it up
take some shots aggressively down the
field you're gonna say something I was
gonna say yeah
Hopkins going up and getting exactly
right that's kind of the team they are
and and last week they lost a few you
really wanna that you get to Shaun
Watson missed a few big throws down the
field one to Demaryius I mean it's that
close to them so I'm betting $10 on the
Texans okay just ten 24 24 213 all right
so I'm gonna tease ahead to see how much
money Simms puts on the RAM but 24
two-thirds but I just I feel confident
that the sexes win the game I do get
scared because I think Todd Bowles is a
pretty good damn defensive coach that he
will hunker down on some of the tells
that the Texans offense has and offense
could be tough sledding at times
this is the first time all season right
that I have entered a bet carrier monkey
zone and then flipped it oh here's why
this is the first road game for the
Houston Texans in about a month and I am
subscribing to this in both of the times
that this is happening today right
member Indianapolis a few weeks ago
played three straight home games
everybody said they were amazing go to
Jacksonville and how many points did
they score zero do not forget that
athletes are human do not forget that
when you get used to being in your bed
for a straight months month and
everything is normal and the routine is
the same and then out of nowhere you're
playing on a Saturday in a different
time zone it could be an issue right
also when was the last road win for the
Houston Texans Sims oh that's right
Houston in Washington remember how much
money you bet on Houston that game I do
you do because they almost lost to
Washington with Colt McCoy having to
come in halfway through the game I
almost blow them out too though but
that's ok Houston's four road wins three
of them have been by three points or
less they beat Washington by two they
beat Denver by to member desert one that
game to Jacksonville they won by 13
indeed a one by three their games are
typically close I originally had this as
Texans win 24 to 17 and then I looked at
it and I said I just think six points
are too much on the road on a Saturday
I'm putting a hundred dollars on the
jets plus six I it doesn't make sense to
me
I fear that sand Arnold is gonna be
running for his life
remember the Houston defense did play
well against Washington but it was
interceptions it was other stuff I think
the Jets keep it somewhat close I got
$100 okay
all right guys moving on second game on
the Saturday slate the Cleveland Browns
visiting the Denver Broncos spread in
this game well how did you feel after
that analysis no I know I I I totally
feel I mean there's a reason I'm betting
$10 so like I could totally see the game
being 20 for 20 but you believe that
Houston's gonna have the edge the whole
time I do I think they'll physically be
winning the game but we might look up at
the score and go damn it's only 1713 I
should wire popped off with seven right
right something like that exactly right
Cleveland Browns visiting the Denver
Broncos on Saturday spread in this game
is Denver minus three weather in Denver
on Saturday high of 56 and cloudy Chris
it's tropical for the Browns the up no
problem with that um interesting matchup
I do think that the Browns offense is
gonna be a pain in the butt for the
Denver Broncos you know again the Denver
Broncos showed issues with play-action
passes and bootlegs last week against
the San Francisco 49ers
it's kind of been their issue when they
find out offensive coordinator you can't
kind of tie those things together it's
it's been a problem for them like where
your head's at I said I think it will be
a problem with Baker Mayfield in this
[ __ ] up I mean they run the ball really
well
they love their throw play-action passes
Baker Mayfield has been throwing the
ball phenomenal and I know he threw
three interceptions a few weeks ago
against the Texans but man he made some
unbelievable plays throughout let's talk
about that basic-ass denver office
without these weapons Sims I know that's
were the same that's the big concern
there certainly it really is I mean the
Denver offense I don't know what to
really expect from it
it's Phillip Lindsay versus Baker
Mayfield yes that's what today that's
what this game feels I mean it does feel
like that and you know again I don't
have great feel for who wins this
football game
I'm putting ten dollars on the Browns
but only 10 I'm picking
the Broncos to win though okay III 220
so I picked a push didn't I since within
that push I have more faith that the
Browns would keep it close
then the Broncos win by more than that
Courtland Sutton is banged up - yes and
it makes me be like I don't know what
receivers Case Keenum sharing - right
since the beginning of 1991 yeah the
Broncos are 11 and O against the Browns
I do not care I believe that our man
Baker Mayfield is gonna put up about 350
against this defense I think Phil
Lindsey could run for about 150 I really
do because the Browns running defenses
ain't that good I have the Browns
winning this game 22 to 20 yeah but I'm
only putting $50 on them just because
they're the Browns but now that I've
heard you say this and I'm feeling
confident I'm putting them in the semi
lock category yeah just because semi
lock it's semi lock is when I feel
confident about an outcome but I'm
betting on a team that's somewhat
unreliable but as we're talking about it
or the Browns really that unreliable
since they've made this change I think
they've been actually really consistent
the last few weeks
well yeah Dean that's been inconsistent
has been the Bronco definitely the only
thing I would throw into that theory is
the thing that would scare me yes as far
as the betting purposes it is Baker
Mayfield on the road in Denver which is
very tough I would say its top five Road
environment as far as loud stadiums it's
a Thursday night pass rushers right so
those are the things that I just thought
of like Baker MIT yeah they've played
better football but Baker Mayfield threw
three interceptions the first half of
the Texas game and it fell away from
them so that was my question I had venue
yeah
Texans defense compared to the Broncos
riots feels like a different level it is
a different ball the Texans are just
more creative the Denver is a little bit
more basic okay and their approach as a
whole they just they they're gonna die
on guys on the edge and they're gonna
play some and a man and some gives me a
little bit of faith in Freddie kitchens
though I hear you I hear I mean I do
think they're gonna find ways to gas
them at times - I just wouldn't be
surprised if the Denver Broncos find a
few ways to catch them as well I think
it's a very close football game all
right guys moving on a Sunday first game
on the one o'clock slate the Green Bay
Packers visiting the Chicago Bears
spread in this game is bears minus six I
want to ask you one question before you
go into that yeah yeah whether whether
part of the cloudy high of 44 on Sunday
in Chicago this is such a one-sided look
yeah but you just sat there and you
looked at Aaron Rodgers and you went god
it scares me a little bit of course it
does right yeah like dude everything
about this game makes you go Chicago but
then you sit there and you go how many
points is Aaron Rodgers worth yeah it's
it's just it's so funny to me it is it's
hilarious and more I this year though I
put less stock in that than other years
because of the one thing I always have
been going back to he can't carry the
team because the pass protection is not
the same as years past where at least in
those years when there was nothing there
he could dance around and [ __ ] nobody's
open but I'll dance for four more
seconds and somebody will come up and
eventually and then shoot first down he
doesn't have that luxury this year
there's a 22nd the NFL and sex per pass
attempt okay I can't even imagine let me
I'll check and this four years I'll have
it when you're done this is one of the
most elusive quarterbacks in the sport
so that just tells you a lot right there
there's been too many times this year
where Aaron Rodgers can't even get to
the top of his drap drought and then
he's tucking and going okay I'm gonna
get hit I gotta you know just kind of go
down here and wave the white flag so I
guess what I look at is this I think
this Bears defense is special and you
know that I think game like last week's
only gonna feed the beast and now they
feel like oh wait we're beyond special
where the monsters the midway now they
have a chance to still stay involved in
the one to seed conversation a little
bit if the Saints fall apart this
weekend in the Carolina game whatever it
may be but either way I don't expect I
Spectre risky and that offense to move
the ball on the Bears
there's too many weapons on the Bears
offense and the biggest thing again
going back to Green Bay is I don't think
they have enough big people again to
stop the run of what the Bears do and
I'm going to pick the bay
I'm putting $10 on the Bears only 10
because of Aaron I think the Bears will
win 27 to 17 but yeah it's just hard for
me to go a lot here because one bad to
risky interception and two unreal
Rodgers plays which I don't thought is
the Green Bay defense matchup with the
Chicago off yeah they can play they can
I mean green bag can place a man-to-man
and that's my question for you they can
do that and Penn is pretty good at
breaking down people what they like to
do in certain formations but I think
this is a few too many weapons across
the board and I think the Bears just do
a little too much on the offensive side
to kind of pigeon-holed them and go oh
when they're in this formation they do
that they're pretty well balanced and
they have enough wrinkles and things out
of all formations where I think it can
make it tough on the pack the Packers
dominance over the Bears is thorough
yeah they've beaten him five times in a
row they've beaten him nine out of the
last ten they've beaten him 15 of the
last 17 Aaron Rodgers the last eight
times he's faced the Bears I looked this
up yeah his touchdown to interception
ratio is 24 to 1 yeah think about that
yeah it doesn't matter if it's Vic
Fangio they've had pretty good defenses
over the years the last eight times 24
to 1 Rodgers has won the last six in
Chicago hasn't played there in two years
and missed that matchup last year right
the Packers are oh and six on the road
this season so as we get excited about
them blowing out the Falcons they've
done well in Green Bay because they have
not won a game on the road this season
yeah the main message that I wrote down
for this is kill the king kill the king
every show i watch whether it's Game of
Thrones or anything that involves that
and there's a tyrant that has been
wreaking havoc on a group of people for
a long time when he is weak is when you
take the stab right and that's what this
feels like yeah it does
Chicago had Aaron Rodgers season over
there up 21 nothing 21 3 in the first
game of the year they
knock Aaron Rodgers out their new trade
khalil Mack rips the ball out it's a
changing of the guard and he comes Aaron
Rodgers he cometh back he descended from
the skies and we all looked at each
other when this season is amazing
Chicago is looking for vengeance
Chicago is looking to say not only you
definitely not making the playoffs but
you no longer have control over us I
have the Bears winning 28 to 10 I could
see that but I'm only putting $100 so
it's hard because that's my standard bet
and I just don't feel that confident
because Aaron Rodgers finds Davante
Adams and Miller Biscay throws like some
interception to Joy here Alexander and
I'm sitting there going and they got to
cover six I really see the game closer
to your I made it 27:17 just because of
the Rodgers factor like hey listen the
building probably had like 27 I would 20
I did those are the thoughts some went
through my head 31 third I wrote down
Aaron is entering a wood chipper I mean
this is gonna be brutal
it's gonna be brutal if teams like
Arizona and Buffalo who have given Green
Bay all they can handle on offense you
know Arizona they lost Buffalo they won
that game but if anybody went back and
watched that game the offense couldn't
do crap all day long it was just a few
matters that was Green Bay wins 22 to
nothing and Aaron comes after the game
and says the offense yeah like yeah cuz
he had to work so hard to make anything
happen
yeah I think the Bears are gonna be all
over their Chicago if they want to go
man they could put fuller on Davante
Adams at those times yeah I just might
lock the Rogers thing is scary
alright guys moving on next game here at
one o'clock the Detroit Lions visiting
the Buffalo Bills spread in this game is
Buffalo - two and a half whether in
Buffalo on Sunday high of 38 light rain
and ice in the forecast gosh tough game
to pick they're both similar ice well
that just made me feel more confident
about my so yeah well I mean if you're
talking about ice - you Pig Buffalo yeah
I did yeah Saturday Oh Patricia dollars
okay I get $50 on Buffalo - - lets get
that out of $10 on Buffalo
okay I think the bills will win 22:17
I had them winning 22:16 you [ __ ] so I
do I think that I break it down lay as
both teams want to run the ball both
defensive coordinators McDermott and
Patricia will be all over the past games
for both of these football team so which
guy can run which guy can run and make
maybe a few other plays that the other
guy can't and I'm gonna go with the
young stud right now in Josh Allen don't
throw picks Josh and you know they got
guys who were you know I don't know how
to say this guys like young guys like
Robert Thomas and Isaiah McKenzie they
don't give a [ __ ] that they're not
playing for anything they're just like
man we're playing hard exactly and also
if you own a Buffalo game it was the
Jets kick returns that really set them
up before so bad an overbite Allen ice
since 2011
against the spread in December the Lions
are one and eight when they're playing
outdoors so you did $10 in the dolls no
I had $50 it's only because I could see
Buffalo do what they did against the
Jets which is Josh throw some dumb pick
to Darius light right and that's enough
to make it easier for Matt Stafford just
to check it down the whole time sure I
just think there's been so much focus on
Patricia let's practice outside let's
practice it's a good thing just so in my
mind very good thing it's still Stafford
outside Stafford outside it's not that I
totally hear you there I'm just saying
for the long projection of the Detroit
Lions yes oh no they should be do
they're doing the right thing yeah a
patrician knows what he's doing
you practice out in the elements it's
going to make your team tougher
especially in December for these type of
situations and when you got to go to New
England when you got to go to Kansas
City go outside you deal with those all
AFC's well then you go inside when you
go to Chicago sure Green Bay or anything
like that but then you go inside and
that's like a gift like oh damn the
balls flying out of my hand here we've
been practicing outside all week it's
been 30 degrees and slick as hell now
we're inside look at this Susu so
there's what's the point of practicing
inside I mean okay if you want to do it
once in a while but there makes no point
and there's no point in practicing
inside all the time
when you play in the NFC North and
really the majority your games are still
going to be outside all right moving on
next game at one o'clock the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers visiting the Baltimore Ravens
spreading this game is Baltimore minus
eight and whether in Maryland on Sunday
rainy with a high of 48 Chris I just
want you to know that you're doing a
smart betting strategy this week thanks
we are both doing the correct strategies
I am evenly displaced you are going for
high variance plays it's the correct
move you need to catch up
yeah okay just say thank you thank you
betting guy yeah that's what I do is
what you do and I'm trying to mitigate
losses right and you're trying to go I
got to push all my chips to the thing
very excited to see the number four yeah
you'll see I don't even know why I don't
always do this because know I used to be
good at picking a game to bet and ever
since I've got into this the whole thing
I've gotten worse I used to be the guy
my friends would call beg what's the
game you pick on Sunday and they big man
Sims you're amazing and now I don't even
want to respond to those texts because I
doubt myself okay - the day after Sims
gives a speech to our listeners that
they need to have more mental speech
today you're breaking down I gave you
this because I just you know I don't
have enough time in the day to give this
everything I want to give it but
Baltimore somebody spotting through it
will be me Baltimore Bucks in Baltimore
tough place to play okay
the Bucs don't have a running game
really to speak of that's not good
not against the Baltimore Ravens okay
Ravens are hands-down one of the more
complicated defense and all a football
especially when they're at home have the
crowd noise they can match up and play
man-to-man I think it will be tough
sledding for the Bucks offense all day
long
now I don't think that the Bucks defense
has been better
they don't do dumb crap on the defensive
side of the ball we talked a little bit
yesterday about their defensive line and
they have some size and there's some
quality there but I think at the end of
the day I do think that the Ravens of
course are on a mission they're the
better football team and I think they
will eventually pound the Bucks into sub
into submission like whatever
a little bit like the game they'll hang
in there and it'd be good but what
happened to the Bucks defense in the
Saints game is they finally just got put
in too many bad situations they got worn
down oh now it's Mark Ingram bust a run
for ten yards
Kamara for five yards and all the sudden
you go damn what's going on here yeah so
I am putting ten dollars on the
Baltimore Ravens and I think they were
going to win the game
send the Raven 24:14 Ravens victory so
sue bucks first road game at about a
month we played three straight home
games and guess what the Bucks record is
on the road Sims gosh one in five yeah
their only win Saints week one jeez I
added it up the Tampa Bay Buccaneers at
home allow twenty point six points per
game really not bad that's like top ten
the NFL on the road guess what they
averaged letting up on the road
the 3539 only they're averaging almost
40 points a game allowed on the road
that's unreal
so I look at Baltimore I'm so funny like
fakes it because it's not about fake I'm
like it's gonna cause my eyes to pop out
of my face be awesome content if that
happens the thing that scares me about
this game is Baltimore's favored by
eight and Baltimore is still a team that
with big point spreads is scary
I was scared during the Raiders game and
that was in Baltimore - yeah and it
required a punt return to make it happen
right and a fumble return to make it
happen I will say though that the
problem that I have with Baltimore and
big point spreads is they are an 11-play
Drive team right there no problem they
you know they're fine when the game
17:30 like they don't care no but from a
betting perspective yes eight is scary
yeah I have them winning 34 to 16 but
I'm only putting $100 on it yeah because
Baltimore is just one of those
situations where it's gonna be close and
you're you're relying on the touchdown
to make it double digit yeah you're
relying on the defensive touchdown or
that I thought about what you said about
V
via Gerald McCoy jpp Vinny curry yeah
they have more big people than the
Chiefs do yeah so I want to lock it
yeah but I just don't think it's worth
it I think that Baltimore like if I'm
bitten moneyline you bet your ass
Baltimore's winning this game but
Sheamus is also one of those guys that
he might cause the Ravens to win by 30
he could also throw some miracle throw
up there to Mike Evans and who the hell
knows I know we saw Jameis gonna run at
the end of last year beat the Saints
late in the year did these type of
things you're right that's it scared me
I go yes 24:14 but Jameis makes some
unreal throat of my Kevin's in the
fourth quarter also does 24 21 and you
go the strength of the Bucks defense is
good for fade chasing facing the Ravens
the weakness is also okay because the
weakness of the Bucks defense is the
secondary yeah and the Ravens still
really damaged their right but I'm still
very confident in the Ravens winning the
game yep we'll see all right guys next
game at 1:00 o'clock the Arizona
Cardinals on the road visiting the
Atlanta Falcons spread in this game is
Falcons minus eight and a half Chris
okay I'm betting $10 on the Arizona
Cardinals okay I I have a hard time
thinking that the Atlanta Falcons are
gonna blow out the Arizona Cardinals
card oh you're so pretty
watch out for those paragon Falcons this
door cured and I let it used to talk
about oh oh no it's the dork to my right
no I was the peregrine falcon from the
sky in talent it's true it's cool
actually yeah I wrote my first note for
this game was who cares this makes me
sad well that's an appropriate note I
think the thing this is what I will jump
out on that I don't see Atlanta's
offense going up and down the field on
the heirs of Arizona Cardinal I just
want to say one thing
yeah this was the line that I went this
makes no sense to me
I agree how was Atlanta favored by
anybody and had like stupid money I
might throw money on this one if I was
just like yeah I've been wanting to lock
this game all day and you're making me
want to lock it man I these are the type
of offenses that I
do you think Steve Wilkes will be all
over Atlantis last five games right
they've scored 20 or less in all five
exactly right so you got a win by you
gotta win like 29 right and Arizona's we
play in teams like the Chiefs and played
teams like Green Bay yeah where I talk
about how it's they know the schemes a
little bit how they do it now the chiefs
of great talent and also what's the
weakness of Atlanta's defense running
backs catching the ball no doubt what is
arizona's entire offense right david
johnson catching the ball right arizona
is a scheme team there is like if
arizona scores 14 points I don't know if
Atlanta is getting 24 I agree I picked
the game and I'm picky I mean ten
dollars in the Cardinals making the
Falcons to win 20 to 16 I picked Atlanta
to win 19 or 16 so there you go this is
crazy
it is crazy I'm officially locking
Arizona plus eight and a half I think
it's a pretty damn good bet
I just I think that Arizona like even
the Detroit game they were losing that
game ten to three I know but at the same
point that's a scary thing about betting
on Arizona Detroit's defense is more
baby stuff in Arizona than Atlanta
because Patricia can get as a game
planner himself where Atlanta's a system
player this is this is what we do this
is what we do we're not changing this is
what we line our been more Seattle
scheme so that's that [ __ ] lock in
Arizona I love that I lock a game that I
put $50 on like we're so dumb like we
were so confident that game and because
we just don't want to bet on the big bad
teams I'm still like like I've had like
three moments this week where I've
literally been like on the train of
Ithaca you're such an idiot like why
didn't you bet all your money on the
Ravens last weekend like I mean I sat
here and was like there's no way they've
out like just blow out the Ravens and I
just totally wussy down it really
bothers me really does I can't even
believe it all right guys next game at
one o'clock the Oakland Raiders yeah
Oakland Raiders on the road visiting the
Cincinnati Bengals spread in this game
is Cincinnati -3 weather on Sunday go
ahead laugh no no say ok weather on
Sunday in Cincinnati a.m. clouds p.m.
on high of 48 I wrote down my first word
for this game gross yeah all capital
letters
gross who's right like I am very happy
that this game is being played cuz it's
one less game that I have to care about
yeah you're right I don't
tension I'll get right to it I'm putting
$10 on the Raiders okay I I think the
Raiders are gonna win this game I really
do just win baby come on Johnny grow dad
I do I'm puttin $50 on Cincinnati I'm
just going with this
Paul Gunther he's from Cincinnati I
think he'd have a great feel for the
offense they don't have to worry about
AJ Green how would the race run deep I
do worry about that certainly it's gonna
be all Jo mix I would think so yes and
Driscoll's been solid
I mean it's solid he really is he makes
a third-down throw to boy right he can
move a little in the pocket do those
things Cal Cincinnati gonna do stop in
Jared cook yeah I think they could have
issues there I think they could have
issues all together you know Jon Gruden
will not abandon the run either he's
going to run the football what was the
temperature again standby
cuz I feel like Derek Carr the cold is
historically really bad that could be
bad you're right I there's certainly
things number that there remember that
game was horrible right I feel like it's
gonna be like mid 50s though I thought I
saw said I thought I saw that during
high of 48 48 all right a little cooler
than you'd like but I don't know
I guess I just look at the Raiders I
still think they're playing tough
football I don't think they've given up
I think Derek Carr is a quarterback
who's not sure if he's gonna be the
quarterback of the team still next year
cuz this head coach is Jon Gruden and
you never know if you're gonna be the
quarterback of a team for Jon Gruden
unless you've won the Superbowl I also
pick Cincinnati because the Raiders are
coming off such a high I hear you
I'm actually gonna go a little the
opposite there it's a motive I think
it's something like that finally gives
them something to go hey look we're not
all in we're not all idiots and we're
doing good things so let's move on I
guess that's where I'll say yeah I have
no idea anybody who bets money in this
game you have to evaluate yourself
mentally okay unless you're Michael
Kendricks and you have inside info that
would be trouble okay anything else on
that game yeah all right moving on next
game the Tennessee Titans visiting the
New York Giants spreading this game
Giants - two and a half whether on
Sunday at MetLife Stadium high of 41
and rain Chris it's a tough game here it
is I don't know I don't it's another
game where I don't you know I'd throw it
up there with the you know just a game
where I have no feel for all together um
I guess what scares me is the Giants big
playability say qualm barkley everything
he does
it is special I mean we think Odell's
playing right we're pretty sure he's
back know he did know there's a chance
he'll end of the year
yeah I think it Hold'em I saw some
alerts today okay so that's that's you
know that's a good thing of course why
um well I mean for the Titans and I'm
betting $10 on the tightness so I am a
Titan you may be a giant but I am a toy
turn I am all around you you giant you
were a big person giant but I am a Titan
I am a god of thunder stealing that for
me it's pretty good okay it's a virus no
way left guy would have been able to
pull I know you wouldn't I like that way
that's a good one what was your score
prediction I'm going 23 21 Titans
victory this is incredible you're going
that - I have predicted a 23 to 21 game
as well then I'll tell you who after I
give you some information obviously
going the Giants cuz if you say the
Giants are winning 23 to 21 I it's scary
well I just go like this the Titans with
extra time the guys they have on the
outside to cover ok the Giants have got
the run game going but I'm not gonna sit
here and go the Giants have impressed me
offensively lately I mean come on the
Redskins are a dumpster fire we know
that the Bears game it was some trick
plays and some horrible play by the
Bears on the offenses out of the ball
and of course sake wanna and a few runs
that I don't think he can pull off
against this defense on this week with
them having extra time not cuz I'm
facing them in fantasy well and the
Titans having the extra time on the
offensive side of the ball
hey the Giants defense you know it's
just nothing special but good pick six
I'm just going with the Titans because
of a little extra time and the fact that
they're a little more deep in the
playoff race and I'm pick
to win a field goal type game the main
reason I'm picking the Giants yeah is
because of where the game is right
since the bye week right the Giants have
played five games three on the road two
at home they're averaging 31 points per
game yeah the reason that's incredible
how many times did we talk about the
Giants inability to score 30 points in a
game yeah it was like a 20-game span
right and now over a span of five games
they're averaging 31 points per game
yeah something's clicking a little bit
and they've learned to get it to their
guys in space namely sacrum yeah but the
real reason is the Titans on the road
there is no team that I find to be more
manic than the Tennessee Titans they're
all over the place on the road this
season they're 2 and 5 and they're only
averaging 19 points per game they can't
score on the road even that Dallas game
are there on the road their offense was
crap for like 90% of the game yeah also
what's really scary they're our last two
games in the road they've allowed 36
points per game
they allowed mound crap alone I thought
I had it them three let me see if I can
do this the Tennessee Titans on the road
the last two games they allowed 30 for
the Texans and 38 to the Colts I just
think they're a team that loves playing
at home and messes up on the road I had
the Giants winning this game 23 to 21
that's why I'm putting $50 on the Titans
to cover the spread
you thought that I wasn't capable of
doing this this week and I will tell you
right now that no human should use this
microphone because I've gotten so close
to this with my sickness that it will
spread malaria through all of the
animals in this kingdom cygwin barkley I
hope you have two yards there's a tough
game to call I mean it really is a 50/50
for because you know like even to your
30 points thing right okay they got a
cheap 14 last week because of Sanchez
right you know they got cheap 14 because
of chase Daniels and there's game was
superfan the reverse touchdown pass by
Odell Beckham Junior
thirty-eight cuz they played the box
exactly it's just it's just we I have no
feel for them I'm going with the team I
mean they got to pick six - exactly
right so I get it I know but I don't
nuts I'd scared me I mean obviously I
didn't bet anything I'm I'm with you i
mean i think the titans are a better
team and they have more to play for and
you're getting two and a half
so obviously that sounds good but it's
really already coming out of sake one
alright guys next game at one o'clock
here the Miami Dolphins on the road
visiting the Viking spread in this game
is Minnesota - seven Chris what's the
status for examine Howard standby Oh
just to hear that pulling up okay either
way okay I still am a team I have
somebody that I mean I believe in this
Minnesota defense it's still extremely
good excuse me did not practice Thursday
still not ready to practice look set to
miss another game damn that's that's
thanks for them either way though I have
a hard time I think at the end of the
day in Minnesota thinking of the Miami
Dolphins are going to be able to move
the ball on this Minnesota defense it's
still extremely talented at all three
levels I mean they played great last
week in Minnesota I mean they almost won
the game single-handedly just by
themselves now the other side of the
ball yeah I don't have a whole lot of
faith in the Vikings I do think we'll
see a little bit of a you know change in
their approach of the football game
which I always think favors them a
little bit because the team that's
preparing for them goes we don't know
what this new offensive coordinators
gonna do they're gonna have to look at
Pat Shermer film from last year thinking
he's gonna bring that out right the
Dolphins are flying high after their
victory and without an exam being Howard
these are the type of games where I
worry that the duck digs feel in cousins
combination comes up so this will be our
last pick and then you can go pee cuz
you're humping the desk as we talk here
I'm going vikings 23 dolphins for 14 I
just don't see the dolphins being able
to muster up enough offense for this $10
on the Minnesota Vikings prevail
dolphins get behind our Viking ship
don't get in front of it or we will sail
over you dolphins and I don't like to
kill
the Miami Dolphins are a surprise seven
and sixteen this year trickling water
stopped trickling the Dolphins are
surprised seven and six this year six of
their seven wins or at home their one in
five on the road they're a different
team on the road also think about the
juxtaposition of energy Miami had their
win of the decade on the Kenyan Drake
miracle right maybe not my leg it was so
good it was so good
Minnesota they found their offense
trickling to get any points think about
Minnesota's defense at hole in the last
few weeks
they held Green Bay's offense to 17 and
they really dominated the entire game
they had the Lions offense to nine yeah
they played the Saints and remember they
let up 30 but one was a pick six right
one was a fumble recovery that led to an
easy score that's right they really did
like they really well they're DS really
good when they're at home they're
different Minnesota is pissed they're
playing for the playoffs the Dolphins
are honestly they got to be happy to be
here I the main analysis I wrote
Minnesota wins this one easily 31 to 17
and I'm putting $200 on Minnesota I
think that this is one of those where
people are gonna go man this Minnesota
offense is really clicking with
Stefanski I think Kirk Cousins comes out
has a few big throws to feeling and digs
and I honestly think this is gonna be
the Dalvin cook game this is gonna be
the Dalvin cook Bay 150 like let's show
everybody how much we love to run the
ball man I didn't know I wasn't have to
do this you're gonna root for Miami
all right guys next game at one o'clock
here Washington on the road visiting the
Jacksonville Jaguars spread in this game
is Jacksonville minus seven and the
weather in Florida on Sunday a beautiful
fall day mostly sunny high of 66 Wow the
Battle of the most embarrassing losses
of teams and a week going on here okay
over them had a running back go like the
length of the field on them yeah fake
one outran Washington Derek Henry ran
through Jackson seriously I mean it was
unbelievable even my little dog
watch Derek Henry and was like whoa that
was really amazing like those men
couldn't get him like that's like I know
they should be embarrassed so okay I'm
putting ten dollars in the Jacksonville
Jaguars okay and you can't do this today
because I don't want to hear it I don't
want you spitting I'm a Jaguar I just
have a hard time that thinking
Jacksonville is going to be pissed they
do have some pride after the way they
played okay so I look at that and go man
their defense gonna be pissed off you
got Josh Johnson starting I can't have
any faith in Washington Redskins moving
the ball on them I don't sit here and go
oh the Jaguars are gonna move the ball
much on Washington Redskins either but I
do think that they can have maybe a few
ugly field goal drives and I think at
some point their defense is going to set
them up for a short field so yes I went
$10 on the Jaguars I think they're going
to win this game 16 to 6 and one of the
most irrelevant boring games to watch
the year go
I'm just looking this not really quick
these are the amount of rushing yards
that Washington's allowed the last few
weeks - 27 130 146 139 103 154 and let
me add one of those teams was
Philadelphia one of those teams was
Tampa Bay yeah like that's that's
embarrassing embarrassed right this
Washington defense has fallen off of a
cliff yeah I know we were hyping up Greg
mineski almost the entire year I look at
this and go Washington was embarrassed
but I think that's just who they are
yeah
Jacksonville was embarrassed and I think
it's because they were playing the
Titans who just have their numbers right
I don't see the Josh Johnson working out
like this is a guy that doesn't know the
offense he came out and admitted that he
had to learn this teammates by playing
Madden and he was able to score towards
the end by relying on his athleticism
and running away right they
no idea what he's about to see in
Jacksonville I mean this guy really
hasn't played snaps in years and
Jacksonville is gonna come out there and
go we want our revenge
plus it's Jacksonville at home and when
you look at Jacksonville at home they
held the Colts to the game before that
at home was the Pittsburgh game they
dominated that game the entire time and
Josh Johnson ain't going Ben
Roethlisberger on it
I am putting a hundred and fifty dollars
on Jacksonville minus seven the only
reason that I'm not going super big is
because with Cody Kessler they've scored
nine points and six points right so but
I think this could be a defensive
touchdown I am very excited
I have Jacksonville's defense as my
fantasy team defense and I am hoping
that they go all like to me this is
Jacksonville going let's play for next
season and destroy this team and I think
everything on Washington is old to me
right like it's old it's injured it's
not working out I feel like they've
packed it in yeah and Jacksonville's
like let's play for our pride $150 and
there's no reason that the Jacksonville
Jaguars can't chose just legs that's how
you doing so there's no reason that the
Jacksonville Jaguars
well not somebody's legs I don't know
what the towel was for how you learned
how to do it but I'm very you gotta get
really deep back in the throat there I
think we need just a try go ahead try
Josh there is no reason why the
Jacksonville Jaguars cannot cover this
spread in this game okay
all right next game on the schedule here
are you okay am I ever okay no okay next
game on the sunday schedule here the
Dallas Cowboys visiting the Indianapolis
Colts spread in this game is Colts minus
three Chris yeah fascinating game one of
the best games of the weekend I'm really
I'm excited yeah it's exciting it's
really exciting I think I look at it
like this
of course we start with the Colts
offense first this great Cowboys defense
which I would say is the second best
defense in football only behind the
Chicago Bears okay but the Ravens three
I would put the Ravens three I would and
okay
I mean hey this Colts offense is always
scary because of their ability to pass
protect that that is something that with
Andrew Luck and past protections a
dangerous combination but how much does
the Saints game they'll give you more
confidence that Dallas can get pressure
no doubt it was one of the things I
looked at to go OK they've they've seen
really awesome old lines and they
weren't like shutout in that game by any
stretch of the imagination they
dominated now the Colts are gonna be
ready for it and they're at home
so that's plays into their favor to a
degree I I guess I do think that they
can make some plays in the passing game
the problem is is that the secondary
they're just too good in Dallas and I
don't think there's enough weapons
across the board for the Colts in this
game especially to scare me there to
where I think they're gonna score a ton
of points they're gonna make a few big
plays T Y we'll get a matchup here or
there that he likes but this Cowboys
defense is really good it's coach really
good and has a nice one or two wrinkles
a game that helped it win football games
now the other side of the ball hey I I
don't know how the Dallas Cowboy offense
is gonna fare against this cowboy I mean
Colts defense either it's pretty crazy
to look at the rankings for the Colts
defense it definitely is they're like
top 15 top 10 I think they're eleventh
total right in total defense if I
remember that right 11th total defense
and yeah I mean there's a lot of things
to admire about the Colts defense their
defensive line is sneaky deep it's
sneaky good whole team tackles well
right they have two linebackers of the
second level just like the Cather's
8th and rushing 15th and past there we
go they're incredible linebackers of the
second level they're like Dallas who are
the other guys other than Darius Leonard
just as far then Walker kid number 50
who's a rookie out of Northwestern
really yeah he's phenomenal number 50
you watched him not heard you mentioned
his name I have I definitely have it's
maybe been a week or two or I mean a few
weeks but it's because I always
mentioned Darius Leonard and it's not
just him so I wanted to give some props
to some other people know he is I would
say he is su Adams Anthony Walker they
got him in the 5th round last year
Darius Leonard was the second round
price year right now you go through the
d-line and you get into their mole
like they're multiple nasarah okay so
Marcus hunt who's a beast and eco Autry
had the good game last watcher he's
always making plays his good player yes
exactly right
jabal sheared how is the Rutgers guy
Kimiko Therese okay he didn't get in
there much yesterday he's been part of
the rotation in fact I was gonna ask
because I watched the Texas film
yesterday and I didn't see him much and
I wondered if there was an injury but
you know guys like Al woods in the
middle Hasan bridge way they start the
Mohammed kid not that I Quan Lewis they
have a true eight deep is what I'm
saying the number ninety Stewart is a
big effort with a class in the middle
right so if they want to play big they
can get big if they want to play small
and fast they can do that to their issue
is their secondary it's not special
house Malik cook urban I mean he's good
he's not quite back to where he was
before getting hurt or what I saw at
Ohio State but there are a few plays
every game where I go ok there's no e
cooker that's you know that was nice
play or he grew he he chewed up a lot of
ground there but the corners are nothing
special to say the least
ah and as much as I like that D line
this is a different offensive line
they're facing here this week this is
not the Houston Texans ok and I do think
Dallas has found their formula and I
think this is the perfect team to work
that formula against I have a hard time
thinking the Colts are gonna win this
football game
I'm putting ten dollars on the Dallas
Cowboys I think that stays close but I
think the Cowboys win 24 to 21 I do
think they're gonna be able to
ground-and-pound a little bit and I do
think they'll be able to strike with
Amari Cooper when he gets kind of manna
manna against these corners the Cowboys
long overtime game I will say though
their defense didn't have to be on the
field at all so he didn't really get an
extra time but first road game for the
Cowboys in a while right yeah they've
been cooked route zing yeah killing
everybody and now they go on the road to
a Lucas Oil Stadium and they get the
Black Plague Colts win this game 24 to
18 and I'm putting $50 on the cult's
gotcha
I have no idea like all of the matchups
make me want to pick the cow
boys I think that the wide reciever
matchup for the Colts favors the Cowboys
I think the wide receiver mansion for
the Cowboys favors the Cowboys I think
they're running off into the Cowboys
favors the Cowboys I don't really see a
running offense on the Colts that favors
the Cowboys it's gonna be Andrew Luck
kind of doing it by himself and makes me
think you're right I just know this
about the Cowboys they remind me a lot
of the Steelers they're know they're an
emotional base team definitely and they
go and they go on Lowe's and for me
they've been the king of the castle for
a month first game on the road I think
they might get punched in the face I
think this defencive line might get
stood up a few times and I'm curious to
see how they respond but I think the
Colts are gonna pull this one out yeah
yeah it's gonna be a fun one I mean I
think it will be a really good day
really I mean you know of course the
defensive coordinator for the Colts came
from Dallas that's Frank Reich of course
has faced Dallas and Christopher
Charlotte so he knows how that works
those are things I've looked at and good
oh I know I just went with the team that
like you just said that I thought was
better
I wasn't sure and coaching matchups yeah
you're taking and your luck I think cuz
do you think any luck at home was a
beast and he is alright guys first game
at four o'clock here the Seattle
Seahawks on the road visiting the San
Francisco 49ers spread in this game is
Seahawks - four and a half whether in
Santa Clara on Sunday rainy with a high
of 61 okay so I do think the 49ers can
move the ball on the Seattle defense
they did that the first time they played
a few weeks ago they really did it was
self-inflicted wounds from the 49ers
that really ended up just ruining the
game and made it look a lot worse than
the actual score the score looked a lot
worse than the actual game was I think
they you know again the Seahawks are a
different defense on the road they're a
different team on the road all together
you know and I don't think their defense
is just gonna dominate the 49ers and I
think these are the type of defenses
that you know Kyle Shanahan has a great
feel for when he kind of knows what
you're lining up in and he can expose
rules you know that's that's where he
makes his magic and historically he's
had pretty good history against the
Seattle scheme in general so I think
running the ball finding a few Qi
bootleg and play-action passes that will
all be there the big thing with the
49ers is do they screw it up do they
drop a pun do they fumble does Nick
Mullens throw a dumb interception when
you really look at their losses and
things like that or bad losses or
anything that's what's happened to them
now the other side of the ball you know
hey I do think it'll be tough sledding
for the Seahawks offense I do I don't
you know this 49ers front we've talked
about it it's respectable they're big
they can overpower you at times and
there I think this game will then go
back to relying on Russell Wilson having
to make plays and the 49ers are just a
hair too aggressive at times and I think
that he will have a chance to make a
handful of plays and come through I'm
betting $10 on the San Francisco 49ers
Niners this is the worst song I've heard
in my life good thing they didn't
publish it don't publish it but I think
the Seahawks doin a 24 to 20 game last
three home games for San Francisco
they've averaged 26 points a game last
three road games they've averaged 13 San
Francisco is better offensively at home
Seattle is a much worse team on the road
yeah the last time these guys played to
go into what you were saying right the
Niners out gain the Seahawks by a
hundred and twenty yards Seattle ran for
a hundred more yards in San Francisco
was a big Chris Carson game yes right
but San Francisco had the ball for five
minutes more I know Nick Mullens threw
for 414 yards and Seattle won the
turnover battle three to nothing
including a pick six pick six that was
100 yards the kid the other running back
fumbled unlike the 9 yard line going in
I think this is super close
I think Seattle wins 26 to 24 and I have
San Francisco $100 okay I was tempted to
pick San Francisco to win I hear you I
was but in the end it comes down in Nick
Mullens and Russell Wilson and I think
Russell Wilson is gonna is gonna find a
way to find a mismatch in this game I
agree
but I think this will be very clear
scrambles because they don't have great
speed on the edge of them secretly
really hoping for San Francisco because
the guy I'm playing in fantasy scooped
up Seattle's defense and I'm like come
on Kyle
right George Kittel the [ __ ] out of it
well I guess there'll be a lot of people
rooting against Seattle in this game I
mean the whole NFC it's gonna be Bruton
against them you know it's funny you
think about Seattle and Seattle just had
a huge Monday Night Football game
they're sitting pretty at five they like
slipped up in this game and now the
Chiefs come to town next week all of a
sudden you go oh crap rate and seven and
you know you're gonna be all the sudden
sitting in this land of oh gosh we need
to win and make certain you lose in
Seattle yeah it's gonna be wild yeah
that's what's crazy about the AFC West
and I know we're gonna but we didn't
even talk about this point is that the
the Chargers have the Ravens next week
Keith's got to go to Seattle so even no
matter who wins tonight it's stories not
done because they still have some work
yeah little meat left on the bone
alright guys moving on for twenty five
on Sunday the New England Patriots on
the road visiting the Pittsburgh
Steelers spread in this game is New
England - to weather in Pittsburgh on
Sunday high of 44 and rainy game of the
day right I think so this is up there
with Indy Dallas
this is up there with no it's it's
probably game day it's the most nd
Dallas in that of the two games of the
day I think right I mean it's the two
games that I look at go I'm excited for
that
100% official Chargers Twitter account
just tweeted out that LaDainian
Tomlinson Dan Fouts and Lance Alworth
are all out for tonight's it's gonna be
a running joke you're right this might
become a thing okay Patriots Steelers I
mean we know the Patriots own the
Steelers I mean they own them like it's
it's like it's like big brother little
brother power right you know you always
hear that like how like even when the
big little brothers better than the big
brother at something he finds a way to
screw it up cuz it's like he chokes and
the most I want to win so bad I'm gonna
just throw the ball over the middle with
no time left and throw it into a crowd
of people because I want to win the game
right here oh it's intercept to be lost
like they've won four straight right
routes right and I mean really I mean
one of them I think they dominated
especially in New England I know last
year was close okay but this is a
different style of play that New England
plays this year okay they actually play
a style that fits Pittsburgh born right
they run right at toured and Hayward
yeah good luck with that okay that's it
I'll say that right away I got to see
that because I know one thing to it
hayward Javad Hargrave have been
whooping people were the last eight nine
weeks so don't know where you're going
here but I know it's a really it so they
can I think control the line of
scrimmage and make the run game
extremely tough Pittsburgh's different
than years past - they're not quite as
obvious on defense they will mix some
men and they're very good at disguising
coverages they're very good at making
different coverages look the same at the
snap which is tough on a quarterback you
go oh it's quarters it's quarters it's
quarters looks like quarters again oh
damn it's quarter quarter half where
it's Tampa - or so they're good at doing
that that's where they become a better
defense than years past in my opinion
and why they're better at defending the
pass in general New England's not as
good at throwing the ball as they are in
years past but still dangerous and I
know they're gonna be able to make plays
and move the ball on Chester Gordon
looked awesome Josh Gordon is officially
the go-to guy for Tom but I kept saying
that to fend Requin we were watching the
game I was like it's all Josh Gordon
slant it so vertical speed right he has
become the new Gronk where there's a big
play Brady no longer goes Gronk Edelman
he goes Josh Gordon then Gronk then
Edelman that's their pecking order for
Brady right now there's no doubt about
that
so that intrigues me now the other side
of the ball it worries me that
Pittsburgh's one-dimensional I mean
Pittsburgh doesn't just they just
decided not to run the ball anymore I
don't know what to say we don't know if
James Connor is gonna play we don't know
I don't know what to say I don't know
and then they need to run the ball a
little bit and they're gonna throw the
ball all freakin game on New England
they will lose because feel like a juju
across the middle game I mean it
certainly does and I think that
Pittsburgh's going to realize and they
did the serious or slow the Patriots are
slow and that if they run the ball and
play action and things like that they
can create some mismatches with
Pittsburgh I mean
with New England even the Patriots are
gonna get a pass rush I have a hard time
thinking that there's no way they're
gonna get a pass rush okay only thing
that hurts Pittsburgh in my eyes is if
they just become to pass every play
because then four is and Belichick are
going to go they're trying to do their
masters of going how are they attacking
us what are they doing in this personnel
what are they doing in this situation
and if they start to get a feel for
their throwing in every play and on
third downs they're liking to do this
they're gonna dial up a coverage where
Big Ben's gonna throw a pic in a big
moment or whatever it may be I don't
think that's gonna happen this time
though I don't I really don't I think
Pittsburgh's gonna be able to move the
ball on doing I think they're gonna be
able to pass protect I also think
they're gonna be a pissed-off much
motivated bunch and they're sick in New
England
how much money you bet and I'm betting
ten dollars on the Pittsburgh Steelers
I'm going to pick them to win the game
27:24 interesting yeah it is interesting
so I looked back at Tom Brady's last two
games in Pittsburgh last year 298 one
touchdown one interception 2016 222 two
touchdowns zero interceptions nothing
crazy right and that was the game where
Landry played two years ago not Big Ben
over the past five years the Patriots
are 16 and four against the spread after
a loss okay that's why a lot of people
are excited about this game for the
patron right
I think the Steelers do very well
offensively and I think you look back
and you even said oh the Patriots did
well last year
no they [ __ ] didn't the Steelers had
the ball 11 minutes longer than the
Patriots and were up eight with four
minutes to go and this was the Jesse
James wasn't a touchdown game the
Steelers had the game won and it was a
call that was really Zach Ertz his
touchdown the Super Bowl that was in my
mind a bad call
Patriots are three and four on the road
they've lost two of the last three the
Steelers just lost an embarrassing
fashion the Patriots just lost in
bone-crushing fashion I think the
Patriots the biggest thing was that
their defense looked awful
the Steelers should have kicked the [ __ ]
out of the Raiders but Josh Dobbs had to
play five tribes I had the Steelers
winning 27
for and I'm putting $100 on it it's like
the first time we've had the same score
yeah I think the Steelers win this game
and I think we're looking at the
Patriots going oh no what is happening
right now what are you saying I was
wrong about though he's like you said
that the Patriots kind of had that game
last year right in Pittsburgh and I'm
saying that no I think the Steelers
actually own that whole game and they
were down eight points with four minutes
left and they got the field goal and
they got it back and they had that one
drive like I thought the Steelers should
have won that game by double digits they
should have yes I mean I don't know
about double digits but they should have
I mean if Steelers couldn't stop them at
the end of the game the Steelers the
past is much more athletic than the
Patriots yeah so many different ways
right but I know it's the axis notes
versus the jimmies and the Joe's this is
like a Tomlin coaching for his job type
of thing right here definitely and the
Patriots are like we're fine you know we
own that game we just have one bad play
we're fine either the Steelers pull the
upset here yeah I I'm with you yeah yeah
I mean the same frickin score ya know
they have better players they match up
good with the style of play this year
the Steelers can play man-to-man better
than years past I think those are the
things that that you know always
bothered me about this matchup
hold on Josh Gordon oh I mean out of
this group here I would love for your
baby Gronk Vance McDonald to outshine
Gronk in this game well I know that
would be cool he definitely can to me as
long as they don't become
one-dimensional just like they can't
overdo it they can't go
oh we're gonna throw the ball 49 times
and we ran the ball 14 times also Big
Ben has to like Big Ben this is the time
of the year where Big Ben's like a lot
of people are talking crap I got to hit
that switch really quick yep and see
what I can do it's crazy though is I
still have faith in the Patriots of
course like it's not crazy I mean
there's like crazy we heard against them
like a long term legacy on this season I
mean I'm just saying for the rest of
this year I still think the Patriots
even than whether they lose this game or
not I mean they could still go to the
Super Bowl
I think they I see a lot of qualities
that I like about their team still yep
all right moving on Sunday Night
Football the Philadelphia Eagles on the
road visiting the Los Angeles Rams
spreading the scheme is Rams my
eleven I assume you saw the alert about
Carson when we need to talk about that
yeah because this is good news
fractured vertebrae Radames yeah no no
tell me okay so carts give me the
information yeah so Adam Schefter
reported that once had a CT scan and it
revealed a fractured vertebra that will
fully heal given time to rest here's why
it's bad right there are now reports
coming out that his fracture in the back
was known for a while but he's only
being aware of the results now reporters
are now reporting that some players in
the Eagles locker room are aware of the
situation and it's causing a huge issue
internally other reporters are now
coming forward and saying the handling
of Darren Sproles his hamstring injury
and other recent abnormalities Eagles
players guess what it's the first year
for this new medical staff and they're
getting very upset here's my thing I was
fine not making the playoffs after the
Eagles won the Super Bowl I was fine
because I wasn't expecting them to do it
but if you're gonna put the back of the
quarterback that you're supposed to have
for the next decade in the hands of a
new medical staff that apparently is not
telling him that he's had a fractured
back I don't think we have an issue that
now has taken all of the goodwill of
that Super Bowl and thrown it away
yeah it's throwing it away because now
it's going wasn't it great to win the
Super Bowl without Carson Wentz and now
we're still gonna have him for a decade
and not risking by running him back
earlier and now you have may have thrown
away the next decade by not telling him
at about a fractured back this to me is
such a huge story because it's the one
guy you don't mess with yeah I think
this is absurd
I think it is scary and I think that
entire locker room now is going if I
can't trust the people taking care of me
who can I trust ya know that's a big
issue it really that was not the part I
was referring to it's good that they
should sit him for the rest of the it's
good to I'm also pleased that it's like
a issue with the vertebra and then it
could heal like I would have actually
been more concerned if he was having
like true lower back spasms and things
like playing that to me because I don't
because I just I
to me this is just structure once it
heals it's good but if you're starting
to deal with like whoa I have like
legitimate like lower back issues
already at this point of your career
that would scare me going further to go
well it's only a matter of time before
it comes back so a back spasm to you is
something that's gonna react or you
can't control it usually yes structural
is structural as long as it gets the
time to just heal it makes me feel
better than going oh he could just swing
a golf club wrong and all of a sudden
his back muscles out like an old man or
just really scared so but the element of
people hiding injuries value what are
you dude if they're if they're if this
ends up being what are you trying to
make it seem like like the gerchas like
get out there this goes on in college I
mean this is this that's like rinky-dink
crap I had this said this happened to
Texas a little bit towards the end of my
stay there like they kind of this is
Varsity Blues on Rodgers you remember
this Sean Rodgers d-tackle of course he
like I'm truly led to believe that he
had a high ankle sprain of Texas for
like the better a year than they he
found out that he had a hairline
fracture that they didn't tell him about
it but they wanted him out there playing
hurt his draft stock he was a dick got
drafted in the second round no no he did
not but yeah that's that's that's
troubling so you're going
huge number here well the other game
fancies me to stop looking at my sheet
look he's cheating he's longer the auto
stared into the math yeah
give us your breakdown and then your
pick um okay so I think that I talked
about the Rams offense first the the
Eagles defense
okay the Eagles their front for like
Fletcher Cox I mean he's gonna watch
film from what he saw last week and go
whoa Goldman and kicks just absolutely
dominated Sullivan and Blythe inside I'm
gonna do that too and he probably will
he'll have moments of that I also think
last week's gonna make a guy like Shawn
maguet McVeigh reap like redo some of
his schemes a little bit and learn how
to protect him also they don't have to
worry about a guy on the edge like
Khalil Mac where they have to give extra
attention but either way that's one
chance I look for the ego so maybe
mess the game up to a degree but the
biggest thing for me is kind of what we
talked about on yesterday's podcast the
Eagles kind of we're on the field all
game last week over plays right
90-something place 90-something plays in
the NFL is insane okay and now you got
the RAM 93 plays in an NBA game right
and then you come off the Rams who are
pissed off played the worst game of the
Shaun McVeigh era okay they're going
back home they're not gonna be happy
about that and then you add the fact of
your secondary trying to match up with
that group negative Ghost Rider now the
other side of the ball ninety-three
plays 45 minutes yes that's that's
devastating to me and then to lose a
football game like that right like I
just think they're gonna be punch-drunk
okay and then you look on the other side
of the ball and you go okay you know
Philadelphia's offense Philadelphia's
offenses issue whether it's Carson Wentz
Nick Foles are Superman they're gonna
have an issue okay it doesn't matter and
they struggle they can't run the ball
they don't protect all that great they
have nobody to be scared of and at the
wide receiver position to back the Rams
off the Rams
I was extremely encouraged by what I saw
on defense last week against the Bears
they finally played the right way like
I've talked about they're just simple
they let their front four get after it
you got playmakers in the backend you
got speed in the backend with your
linebackers in secondary keep your eyes
on the quarterback he throws he throws
it to the left everybody look at that
guy run to him make the tackle it's all
it should be it's only a matter of time
before Aaron Donald gets in there makes
a play or Marcus beaters makes a play or
keep the lead makes a play either way so
at the end of the day I'm putting $1,200
on the brain
what-what-what pill hundred dollars Ryan
yeah la la and it's 38 20 sorry Philly
you gotta go home I don't have any more
rhymes hey yeah but I think they're in
deep trouble they're all running
twelve hundred are you short money now
he's good I don't know I never know I
mean I do the math he's the smartest guy
I've ever seen but he cannot add it is
funny it's hilarious
I mean you could be like two two is five
let the spreadsheet do it for me I don't
think people understand how much Carson
Wentz does for this office on a regular
basis right I was joking when I said
Nick Foles could do something I'm
putting two hundred and fifty dollars on
the Rams I had them winning forty one to
ten oh wow yeah you're seeing like a
repeat of Saints games again that's what
I see yeah I see a defense that's not
gonna be able to get to the quarterback
I see an offense that's been been
hearing about how they got owned on
prime-time Sunday Night Football yeah
Jared Goff looked awful Todd Gurley
looked awful right I think that they're
gonna have a field day I think it's it's
revenge for last year's game I think
it's revenge for what happened and then
this week I think Sean McVeigh is gonna
go in there and go we need to tear the
hell out of these people and the Eagles
like what can they do to surprise them
yeah this has to be kick returns for
touchdowns
this has to be punt return touchdown sir
Cox this has to be Jared Goff fumbling
backwards like it has to be crazy yep
uh yeah I think this was blowout City
I'm surprised it's only 11 I think
should be 16 I wouldn't I was really
scared that that's what it was going to
be I was like damn now because I was
gonna go hard on this all week I didn't
care if it was whence or whoever and
then when I heard once wasn't playing I
was so disappointed because I did when I
opened up the computer this morning I
expected it to go eagle I mean Rams
minus 17 or minus 19 I really and I was
like damn I'm not gonna be able to pull
the trigger on that bet so you should
have $70 in this next game right I got
the math under control over here alright
just make it yes listeners I have $70 on
the Saints for the next game okay I got
the Saints winning 31 21 when I tell the
spreadsheet to do some of d4 to D 19 and
it tells me what it totals it's not
gonna screw it up the Google Docs know
what they're doing next game here I'm
always talking it's how you do
formatting 14 D 19 I've learned these
things in the New England scouting
community you got
in addition in Google Docs I'm gonna be
very honest to all possible future
employers I'm going to write all my
resume that I'm proficient in Excel and
that's only because I know what Excel is
and I can fill in boxes but I'm not
proficient oh I didn't I would argue
that most people write they're
proficient and they're not perfect I
didn't know what Excel was until I
started working in New England that's
unbelievable okay Monday Night Football
here we're HR 1 I got the bleacher he
didn't have an email address until like
2015 yeah what year was that 2011 yeah
12 12 people were getting emails in 2000
this was just I was so disappointed when
I got it's not available email are you
kidding me okay last game of the week
Monday Night Football the New Orleans
Saints on the road visiting the Carolina
Panthers spread in this game is Saints
minus 6 weather in North Carolina on
Monday it is a high of 61 low of 34
clear skies yeah in free fall Carolina
in free fall I don't know what to think
of Carolina right now either way I worry
about Carolina's defense in this matchup
obviously I really do the Saints yes
have not been on their game I do think
the second half they kind of found their
mojo a little bit once again I honestly
think that Sean Payton has been a little
too less creative the last few weeks why
do I think that tell me about that I
just think he's he's lacked a few
wrinkles and his game plan that the
Saints need to get them over the edge
and some of these type of football games
again not bagging on Drew Brees but I'm
going to bag on Drew Brees just a hair
here by saying he's not the type of
quarterback that when the offense is
struggling he's going to make plays at
this point of his career to help the
offense out I'm not trying he's still
awesome he's still in the MVP
conversation calm down fleur-de-lis I'm
here I'm not trying to be a hater I'm
still picking the Saints to win the
Superbowl calm down just chill I'm just
saying at this point of his career he's
not going to get it done when
everybody's covered and there's a little
pastor oh she's not gonna big dodging
people and throw so they need those
wrinkles I have no faith like I said in
the Carolina defense right
and you know the other side of the ball
I'm so encouraged with what I've seen
from the Saints on the defense
I really am you know that's where I just
look at Sean Payton and Dennis Allen and
I just go man you know it work they made
it work they just they understand
football and you know Lefko you think
about what they've done defensively like
this just came to me today and we might
have talked to like okay they had the
Rams game where they let up 35 points
since then it's 14 points at 7 points
it's 17 points at 13 points it's 14
points and even before the Rams game it
was pretty good and trending in the
right direction there as well so they
have found the right format they have
the big people up front to be fine with
what Carolina does and they'll play
smart coverages in the backend
I think the Saints win this game 31 to
21 I'm betting $70 on the Saints I
wanted to go hard but the fact that it's
in Carolina it's outside it's night time
I don't trust a breeze will be totally
on his game dissecting them and I do
think this will be the last ditch effort
for Carolina I think this is a 24 21
game and the Saints score a touchdown
with like four minutes left to put it
away so from a betting perspective the
Saints have covered six games in a row
against Carolina owned them last year
yeah here is the truth though that gets
me excited everyone's talking about the
Carolina five-game losing streak four of
those games were on the road okay yep
remember home field is a huge deal go
look at almost any team in the NFL
they're great at home and they're bad on
the road okay so four of those five
games have been Road games their only
home game was a complete dominance of
Seattle that was marked with bad plays
in the red zone and missed field goals
Carolina looked so good in that game
against the playoff team but because
it's part of a five-game losing streak
it's just chalked up as another loss
that's the loss I really broke them I
feel like in four of their last five
games the Saints have not allowed a 300
yard passer which goes to what you were
saying about the passing I look at this
as the last gasp from Carolina
you know what else it is it's the third
straight road game for the New Orleans
Saints I had to go to Dallas yeah they
made it go to Tampa Bay and now they're
going to Carolina because of the
Carolina defense and that's the only
reason I'm still picking the Saints to
win because I think that Sean Payton's
gonna be able to dial up when he needs
to to get the win but I have the Saints
winning 33 to 30 and I have Carolina
covering the six and I'm putting $100 on
it okay
all right guys that means that we've
agreed on 13 of the 16 and we've
disagreed on three which means you need
to route very hard for the Houston Texas
Conference what are you is the other one
Houston Jeff Houston Cincinnati Oakland
and New Orleans Carolina didn't you guys
disagree on Dallas Indy - who did you
pick I think you did so we had four so
you need to spread sheet don't lie but
what's really interesting in all those I
have 50 I have a hot so you need to
honestly get all of your picks wrong and
get the Rams right and that way it'll
get somewhat closer because I'm a little
bit insulated because we've agreed on so
many yeah right
but you really need you all of your
picks really to be wrong yeah locking I
have no problem
which one's the ones what are your big
bets so my big bets this week I have 200
on Minnesota right against Miami and I
will be locking it and do you feel
confident in that you're sniffles into
the microphone I don't feel confident
that why cuz I don't know I mean have
you seen the Vikings offense it sucks
yeah they have a new OC my I have a
hundred fifty on Jacksonville right
against Washington yeah I feel pretty
confident on that I think that's it yeah
that's one I look at and go maybe I
should have gone more to I have 250 on
the Rams - 11 and now so I know you're
not confident about Minnesota I'm gonna
make them a lock and I think I'm gonna
so my question is is I have Arizona Plus
eight and a half you think I should lock
it and locking Arizona plus eight and a
half ago sick that's really well here
are the other ones I'm thinking about
yeah
I'm gonna do Minnesota I'm gonna do
Jacksonville I'm going to do the Rams do
i do Pittsburgh plus two or Arizona plus
eight and a half ooh
I think I'm doing Arizona plus eight and
a half okay I'm gonna ride it yeah
all right left go you know what time it
is it is time for guaranteed to lose
Simms have you done it yet I have done
it I'm trying to make it so you could
see clearly there
it's those ones there okay okay okay
these ones not all right one there
Nick G let's hit that music idea to be
hello guaranteed to lose there's no
person that I trust more than Chris it's
Chris that first game we're headed to
the Big Apple pal
hey thanks there buddy old pal and this
matchup I think the Jets are guaranteed
to lose Lego they can't win this are you
kidding me Houston's DS for real the
Jets got injuries on offense and their
offense ain't that good anyways I like
Houston just doing the diddly da doop de
doop into the lap at 410 in New York
they call Houston Houston how dare you
disrespect them that's crazy all right
next place we're going calling the shot
the car says go and that's why I say
Chicago
hey Oh Aaron Rodgers Roger I'm sorry
sorry but you can't mess with the
monsters of the Midway
oh you can't no you can't just Khalil
mad hey Oh N I don't trust compactors
run defense either Chicago gonna dance
tippy-toe all there where that back the
night
and green baize are you guaranteed to
lose when I think girl the place that I
know I think about to mole Yoho Yoho oh
sorry
Tampa you gotta go go I don't trust it
your Tampa Jameis will turn the ball
over
Baltimore's defense is real and I'm so
sorry
Tampa cuz I love you I'm playing my
saxophone hey how's the judges take me
to La si oh we're going to LA let go and
Oh your Eagles they in trouble big and
loose I got a call this week from Sharon
left Co she said Chris stop talking my
mom oh sorry I've talked to Bruce too
though anyway alright it was a three-way
on the phone I mean I'm funny guy Oh
bizarre egos you're gonna lose the Rams
are pissed and your defense ain't good
and stop it much right now
sorry Philadelphia like a wise kid once
said up your ass Philadelphia skip it
about baseball baby whoo let's go down
to New Orleans Carolina but it's the way
we should end with this music is going
to jazz town
hey Carolina you can lose sorry sing it
to a fellow because this is this is New
Orleans and we jam and jazz here talk
slow too and Mary oh and we're yeah
we're a Super Bowl team and Carolina
you're a dumpster fire they feel abrecan
Oh Carolina I guarantee you're gonna
lose you know why because I am the
Oracle camel I'm a ding-dong whatever I
say goes on this segment who are the
Oracles law hey he can't beat the Saints
all right just to be clear there cuz I
don't even know if I said it right the
Jets are guaranteed to lose the Packers
are guaranteed to lose the Bucs are
guaranteed to lose the Eagles are
guaranteed to lose and the Carolina
Panthers I was still in my jazz mood I
don't even know them all you're gonna
like that song Nick I like it Nick I
like it when you go man and that is the
week 16 week 15 picks podcast all right
all right enjoy the games
Thursday and on Saturday how are you
gonna be so you're gonna be rooting hard
you gonna root card for the Eagles to
cover now right yes I'm gonna lock the
rims yes you're in it with me then lower
Sims peace out homey or fedra good
evening everybody
the lef koe man says holla holla holla
holla holla psyche rooting for the
Eagles I talk to you guys later